is June still on the table well let me
just speak for myself I think the
combination of the jobs report on friday
and the brexit consideration justify
patients but i'm speaking only for
myself the meeting is live I don't know
how it's going to come out the committee
could arrive at a decision to increase
the Fed Funds rate but as I assess the
situation currently I'm prepared to be
patient what does patient mean would
July be a meeting at which you would
consider a rate increase well I think
patient for me again means first getting
beyond the brexit boat and seeing how
the data come in for the next few weeks
my fundamental view is that the economy
remains on a moderate growth track let
us say around two percent and that it
will be sustained for the rest of the
year and beyond so I'm not really
changing my overall view of the economy
just because of the jobs report on
Friday however the weakness of the jobs
report is something that I think
justifies a little bit more patience if
you don't think it's a new trend then
what do you think happened to the jobs
report I think there are two possibly
three ways that can be interpreted the
first is that it's in indicating a
slowdown in the economy I don't believe
that's the case as I just said I don't
believe that's the case the second
interpretation is it's the natural
slowing of job generation as we get
closer and closer to full employment and
that's clearly a possibility the third
is that what we've seen with this most
recent report and the revisions to the
early reports is simply the waxing and
waning of data the to-and-fro that we
see in the numbers in an economy that's
never going to be totally linear so
that's possible as well the key point
for me is I don't it does not take me
off of my basic view of the economy
growing at around two percent